dominic on sky news in the uk
thank you for taking my question um
you said some time ago that russia had
no intention to invade ukraine i think
today you said that russia did not
invade ukraine when it clearly has it
also said that russia would not hurt
civilians and thousands have been hurt
their homes destroyed and it seems that
hospitals being
attacked
why should the ukrainians take you
seriously with all due respect why
should they believe a word you say and
the rest of the world
as for the hospital and maternity wards
i talked about this but you didn't
listen to this and you're not going to
show this
and nobody will say
that three days ago with the security
council of the united nations we explain
what happened to that maternity war
as for
the statements
who is going to do what and who is not
going to do what
until the last moment we wanted to
resolve the matter in a diplomatic way
we presented an extensive document on
our
bilateral agreement with the us and also
nato and also covered all the questions
on european security including all
countries uh on the continent including
ukraine we were told that ukraine is
ours
and we will deal with ukraine and we
will resolve uh the future of ukraine
and
we proposed
none
we didn't we proposed not creating any
threats on the ground in ukraine to the
russian federation and putin explained
very clearly why he took that decision
to conduct a special military operation
and even if you're not allowed to talk
to your listeners about this you could
they could yourself read this document
and understand our logic it's it's very
clearly explained we want a ukraine
which will be friendly demilitarized
ukraine which
would not
create any threats
for creating a nazi state
ukraine where there would be
a russian culture and language and the
orthodox church is is not forbidden
it's not banned
all of that was uh reflected in the
in their laws
and
all our calls all our
uh
all our
uh attempts to
to
our
contact with our western colleagues to
influence the ukrainians on this
they failed
and
when the ukraine
passed a law where only ukrainian is fit
for use on the territory of
of
their territory
and all other languages were
discriminated against in school in other
universities and
hungary and bulgaria started to explain
to express their
discontent
ukraine then made an exception in a very
elegant way uh exception uh out of this
law for european union languages and
only russian
was left as a discriminated language
and uh the west went quiet
it just emphasizes the fact that west is
only interested in ukraine working
against anything that is russian
the west has done in relation to the
referendum
in crimea this is a double standard
there was there was no
referendum in kosovo
but uh natto nato created a situation
where
by bombing yugoslavia they created the
conditions for kosovo
and when
when they wanted independence uh the
whole west
just applauded it and supported it why
albanians can do this when russians
can't do this albanians in yugoslavia
they were not just allowed to do this
they were stimulated they were pushed in
that direction
and they had this uh
the
purpose of
of united kingdom and other countries
was
not to have a
too large a country in the baltic uh
in the balkans
and they have the same goal in relation
to russia
and we understand that this is not about
ukraine this is about the aggression
against anything russian
interests religion language culture
safety
and
a lot of things and of course now the
reaction of the west to our actions
um
a very
very aggressive reaction
and this
is
yeah it really demonstrates the fact
that this is a fight
for
for life